Do you know if you take people,
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of,
you know,
that they know they need to overcome in
order to meet their goals,
their self defined goals.
If you can teach people to stand up in
the face of the things they're afraid
of,
they get stronger and you don't know
what the upper limits to that art
because you might ask yourself like if
for 10 years if you didn't avoid doing
what you knew you needed to do by the
depth,
by your own definitions,
right?
Within the value structure that you've
created,
to the degree that you've done that,
what would you be like?
Well,
you know,
there are remarkable people who come
into the world from time to time and
there are people who do find out over
decades long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were.
If they said if they spoke their being
forward and they get stronger and
stronger and stronger and we don't know
the limits to that.
We do not know the limits to that.
And so you could say,
well,
in part perhaps the reason that you're
suffering unbearably can be left at your
feet because you're not everything you
could be and you know it.
And of course that's a terrible thing to
admit and it's a terrible thing to
consider,
but there's real promise in it,
right?
Because it means that perhaps there's
another way that you could look at the
world and the number another way that
you could act in the world.
So what it would reflect back to you,
it'd be much better than what it
reflects back to you now.
And then the second part of that is,
well,
imagine that many people did that
because we've done a lot as human
beings.
We've done a lot of remarkable things.
And I've told you already,
I think before that today,
for example,
about 250,000
people will be lifted out of abject
poverty.
And about 300,000
people attached to the electrical power
grid we're making.
People were lifting people out of
poverty collectively at a faster rate
that's ever occurred in the history of
humankind by a huge margin.
And that's been going on unbelievably
quickly since the year 2000.
The UN had planned to have poverty
between 2000 and 2015 and it was
accomplished by 2013.
So there's inequality developing in many
places and you hear lots of political
agitation about that.
But overall the tide is lifting everyone
up and now it's a great thing and we
have no idea how fast we can multiply
that if people got their act together
and really aimed at it.
Because you know,
my,
my experience is with people that were
probably running at about 51 percent of
our capacity.
Something mean you can think about this
yourselves.
I often ask undergraduates how many
hours a day you waste or how many hours
a week you waste.
The classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day.
You know,
inefficient studying,
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch,
that you don't even care about that make
you feel horrible about watching.
After you're done,
that's probably four hours right there.
Now you think,
well that's 20,
25 hours a week.
It's 100 hours a month,
that's two and a half full work weeks.
It's half a year of work weeks per year,
and if your time is worth $20 an hour,
which is a radical underestimate.
It's probably more like 50.
If you think about it in terms of
deferred wages,
if you're wasting 20 hours a week,
you're wasting $50,000
a year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
$50,000
a year as a way bigger catastrophe than
it would be for me to waste it because
I'm not going to last nearly as long and
so if your life isn't everything,
it could be.
You could ask yourself,
well,
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you?
You be who knows how much more
efficient,
10 times more efficient,
20 times more efficient.
That's the prieto distribution.
You have no idea how efficient,
efficient people get.
It's completely.
It's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stopped making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time.
Not only do they not do what they should
to make things better,
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or or
homicidal or genocidal or all of those
things all bundled together in an
absolutely pathological package.
If people stopped really,
really trying just to make things worse,
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that.
So there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability,
social judgment,
both of which are are,
are,
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt.
And that's the thing that's interesting
too,
is that like one of the,
another thing I've asked often asked my
undergraduate classes is,
you know,
there's this idea that people have that
people have a conscience and you know
what the conscience is.
It's,
it's this feeling or voice you have in
your head just before you do something
that you know is stupid,
telling you that probably you shouldn't
do that stupid thing.
You don't have to listen to it strangely
enough.
But you go ahead and do it anyways,
and then of course exactly what the
conscience told you was going to happen
inevitably happens so that you feel even
stupider about it than you would if it
happened by accident.
Because you know,
I knew this was going to happen.
I got a warning.
It was gonna happen and I went and did
it anyways.
And the funny thing too is that that
conscience operates within people and we
really don't understand what the hell
that is.
So you might say,
well,
what would happen if you abided by your
conscience for five years or for 10
years?
What sort of position might you be in?
What sort of family might you have?
What sort of relationship might you be
able to forge?
And you can be bloody sure that a
relationship that's forged on the basis
of who you actually are is going to be a
lot stronger and more welcome than one
that's forged on the basis of who you
aren't.
Now,
of course,
that means that the person you're with
has to deal with the full force of you
in all your ability and your
catastrophe.
And that's a very,
very thing to negotiate,
but if you do negotiate it well,
at least you have something,
you have somewhere solid to stand and
you have somewhere to live.
You have a real life and it's a great
basis upon which to bring children into
the world,
for example,
because you can have an actual
relationship with them instead of
torturing them half to death,
which is what happens in a tremendous,
a tremendously large minority of cases.
Well,
it's more than that too because,
and this is what I'll close with and
this is why I wanted to introduce social
units since readings to you,
you see,
because it isn't merely that your fate
depends on whether or not you get your
act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being.
It isn't only your fate,
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with.
And so you know,
you think,
well,
there's 9 billion,
7 billion people in the world.
We're going to peak at about $9 billion
by the way.
And then it'll decline rapidly,
but 7 billion people in the world.
And who are you?
You're just one little dust mote among
that 7 billion,
and so it really doesn't matter what you
do or don't do,
but that's simply not the case.
It's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network,
you're a node in a network.
Of course that's even more true now that
we have social media.
You'll,
you'll know a thousand people at least
over the course of your life and they'll
know a thousand people each and that
puts you one person away from a million
and two persons away from a billion.
And so that's how you're connected and
the things you do.
They're like dropping a stone in a pond.
The ripples move outward and they effect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend.
And it means that the things that you do
and that you don't do are far more
important than you think.
And so if you act that way,
of course,
the terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do.
And you might say,
well that's better than living a
meaningless existence.
It's better for it to matter.
But I mean,
if you really asked yourself,
would you be so sure if you had the
choice,
I can live with no responsibility
whatsoever.
The price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters,
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that.
It's not so obvious to me that people
would take the meaningful path.
No.
When you say,
well,
nihilists suffer dreadfully because
there's no meaning in their life and
they still suffer.
Yeah,
but the advantages,
they have no responsibility.
So that's the payoff.
And I actually think that's the
motivation.
Say,
well,
I can't help being nihilistic.
All my belief systems have collapsed.
It's like,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless
suffering,
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the martyr.
So that's a pretty good deal.
All things considered,
especially when the.
When the alternative is to bear your
burdens properly into live forthrightly
in the world,
well,
what Solzhenitsyn figured out in so many
people in the 20th century,
it's not just him,
even though he's the best example,
is that if you live a pathological life,
you pathologize your society,
and if enough people do that,
then it's held really,
really,
and you can read the Gulag archipelago.
If you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like,
and then you can decide if that's a
place you'd like to visit or even more
importantly,
if it's a light.
If it's a place you'd like to visit and
take all your family and friends because
that's what happened in the 20th
century.